well we are learning new details about
the man accused of tacking speaker Nancy
Pelosi's husband Paul with a hammer
police say that David depap has admitted
that he had other targets as well
including an oscar-winning movie star
Paul Pelosi suffered a skull fracture in
that attack Scott McFarland has more on
all of this Scott good morning this was
very scary to hear the more details that
we heard yesterday yeah gal authorities
made a series of Revelations about this
case including a police investigator who
testified Wednesday that David depap
told them there's evil in Washington
that he was targeting Nancy Pelosi and
that he had plans to hold her hostage
the pap allegedly said he later planned
to kidnap President Biden's son hunter
in California and Target the state's
Governor Gavin Newsom and movie star Tom
Hanks we also learned new details from
First Responders that when they
allegedly arrived on the scene officers
witnessed Pelosi and depat wrestling
over that hammer to Pap allegedly used
to break into the house before they
could enter Ravine Pelosi was struck in
the head and knocked unconscious while
the court proceeding was underway 82
year old Paul Pelosi was here in
Washington with the house Speaker for
the ceremonial unveiling of her portrait
he told CBS News his recovery is coming
along but is a slow process the Papas
pleaded not guilty to state and federal
charges including threats against a
federal official and attempted murder
he's back in court in two weeks in local
court for arraignment Tony
all right Scott got it thank you very
much